let's turn to amber phillips staff
writer for The Washington Post amber
good morning hey good morning so it has
been a stunning repudiation of the
america first doctrine as arrow points
out this week the president president
Trump is taking a remarkably hawkish
stance on a number of situations around
the globe yeah to what degree do you
think that is it this is a meaningful
change of heart to what degree is it
circumstance and whim we're trying to
figure that out I think the president
has has made very clear from the very
beginning that all his policies are up
for negotiation and so it feels like you
know who whenever that policy is being
negotiated who's ever is in the room
with him and has the best argument is
the one he's going to go with I'll give
you an example you know in he met with
the Chinese President this week and then
he came out and said Oh China is no
longer currency manipulator like a huge
flip-flop I don't think the president
has some grand plan to try to moderate
toward the middle if he if he did he
would have done that during the campaign
in fact he tried to do that and it
didn't work right he get pivoting back
to his base so I think this is just him
trying to figure himself out trying to
figure his administration out and being
more open than other politicians other
presidents to have any traversal
complete reversal just be okay with it
how does that play with his his base
then though at this point so far they're
okay with it right I'll give you the
example of Syria Trump during the
campaign mentioned bombing Isis yes but
he said he kind of wanted to stay out of
Syria's recently as last week then they
bombed them a washington post-abc news
poll said eighty-four percent of
republicans approved of that by contrast
in 2013 when President Obama was
considering bombing Syria twenty-two
percent of republicans proved that but
do you think there's a lesson there
about Trump space that they're less
concerned with foreign policy and its
really the domestic agenda that they
want to see untouched in terms of
trump's campaign promises and if he
pivoted on some of his positions on
trade or the economy that that would
resonate more with his base yeah that
remains to be seen right because he
hasn't yet pivoted on those to the
degree he has unformed but if we're
talking about the ascendant wings
White House and let's talk about that a
little bit gary cohn yet one of his
advisor seems to be a senate he's a
former goldman sachs person is it your
sense that he's going to be moderating
the president on a host of issues
including domestic ones it certainly
seems like he's has rising influence in
the White House this week just given
Trump's moderation toward foreign policy
in general I think gary cohn it aligns
with the president the sense that he's
not ideological again he's a New York
guy he's had said I man I'm not a
Democrat I'm not a Republican I just
want to make deals and Trump can kind of
drive with that he's not ideological
either there's been a lot of talk about
a possible shake-up in the White House
this week that Steve Bannon has been
marginalized where does that stand at
the end of the week sure we're trying to
figure it out there is anything the
shake-up in the white yes I feel like
and listen all administrations have
their drama but this seems more dramatic
than normal and it feels like Trump puts
the bannen on on a warning notice by
giving an interview to New York media
early this week by saying oh that's
Steve guy nah he came on late my
campaign I'm my own strategist I mean a
lot of Bannon types in the White House
feel like that was a warning shot to
Bannon that Trump isn't feeling his sort
of ideological firebrand go get'em you
know kind of vibe like with the travel
ban that got rolled out didn't go very
well Steve Manon's off the National
Security Council this could be a sense
that trumped just doesn't like Steve
benen at this moment i'll also add that
our Washington Post White House team is
reported his family doesn't like Steve
Bannon the Jared Quinn that's an
important thing in this yet White House
yeah Anna does not have a lot of allies
inside 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue and that
could prove critical amber phillips from
the post thanks as always thank you